[Music]
I met him as a single parent and we've
been together 32 years because I refuse
this proposal that's fair but I think
the same way you did on me I was still
forgiving because I think that him
having a bit of front with someone is
not less important than me and our
relationship and the foundation that
we've built so there's no way would I
put even though my child's old and I've
got no reason to stay because of a child
I will stay because
I'm worth better than the piece of
France
I have to respond I'm so sorry the same
way you think that I can't comment
because I don't have children I can't
accept what you're saying to me because
you're not in a marriage what is the
difference between being with someone
for 32 years and being married with a
ring for very different other than the
ring there's a difference what's the
difference tell me
yeah and that's fine now I'm asking you
I'm asking you I don't know the
difference can you educate me and tell
me what the difference is in somebody 32
years right no problems and being
married for two years there are people
who are together for 30 plus years and
then they get married and then they get
divorced in two years because of the
difference there's a difference
no no wait so so you said there's a
difference name it I think I think the
commitment is different I think the
level of commitment is absolutely
different to when you're just cohabiting
and you're living together on your okay
what is the difference
okay if you're from a religious Bank for
example but okay 32 years versus okay 32
years versus a five-year marriage which
one is more committed I'm I'm a
Christian I'm a religious person okay
for me I think that making that vow in
front of God in front of witnesses is a
whole different ball game to you being
in a relationship for 50 plus years
I'm not religious what's my religion
what what my beliefs don't believe that
I should go and sway before God or write
in a bit of paper if I think it's just a
contract yeah and that's fair I can I
can accept that but again
just if you let me finish I accept that
I understand that but this is why I'm
saying that in my opinion there is a
difference so because of my backgrounds
my experiences in life and everything
things I've seen people have spoken to
all that kind of stuff it's just
different it's just there's a difference
which is the difference
it's just it's no it's just making it
it's a decision I'm asking you what is
the difference other than that I've only
heard religion yeah I've talked to the
different level of commitment but
religion is
it's like it's like this is kind of what
women do it's like we say nothing it's
like you're not here with me no I'm
literally
I'm literally the words wait I'm
the words you're saying and it's like we
say you say commitment okay what what is
the difference what is the commitment
okay marriage is something that you
shouldn't walk away because it's a
religious thing you do right the New
Concept of marriage that is done in this
day is very different to why people
married before and marriage is a
commitment you make in front of God to
stick by each other in a relationship
that you're cohabiting if you aren't
just say you might not be religious or
for whatever reason you can walk away
whereas in marriage religious terms you
vow to God that you're going to be with
them okay okay so so both of you both of
you you're saying it's different more
committed but you said you would leave
if your partner does something you don't
like like cheat
because you're and you're separated so
so these and this is and this is the
church
every every bought a house together
right and then we decide to separate
would the law see me any different for
being within 32 years or five years
married how will the Lord see me yes the
Lord won't see you as his partner they
won't see you as his legal partner when
you tick a box you won't say it
I actually are cohabiting but again even
then you're commit when you're married
the law sets stronger standards on that
marriage and relationship and how things
are divided if there's an agreement
where you both own the house it doesn't
matter whether you're married or not but
that's different I'm not talking about
when you both own the house obviously
it's going to equally be divided that's
what I'm trying to say 32 years you're
going to have things jointly anyway
Auntie coming back to the comment you
made so now I want to flip it to just
say a woman and a man are married
happily the woman steps out for whatever
reason she steps out she comes and tells
her man I've now married he then walks
away is he the one that's now breaking
the marriage I said it's down to whoever
wants to do to forgive him okay so oh
man enough they've got children that
they should both stay and work it out
I've said this before and people slitted
me through I I would stay you would stay
if my wife stepped on me I would stay
under under no circumstances without the
kids being there would I stay but when
the kids are there I have to put my kids
first
repeatedly
no no no wait wait can I just say this
back to your point about marriage and
the kids not once has one person said
let the man have the kids and you walk
away that's what Islam says
not once has anybody here said that no I
agree with that because you're unhappy
in the marriage you got cheated on are
you happy to let the man have the kids I
would and then you do the legal part
where you pay child support and you
you're not happy no you don't you don't
know I'm happy with you you didn't let
me answer the question I would be happy
with that what listen for me I'm doing
whatever I think is best for my children
if I'm going to be in the marriage and
I'm going to be miserable and I can't
let go of this hurts yeah I could that's
not going to be good for my children so
if for me leaving this marriage is
actually more beneficial to raise my
children in that with healthy parents
I'm going to that for me I'm assessing
whatever is best but I don't have the
mindset where I I don't believe every
woman is is able to let go of this like
there's certain things I might I may be
able to tolerate and but then cheating
is where I draw the line but there's
something else that you might be talking
about I'm like oh I'm fine
I just want to say that the women from
the 1950s would think we were so soft I
swear to God because they stayed when
their man had a whole family across town
and they weren't leaving they were not
wait let me just ask a quick question
yeah so do you see a man stepping out
and a woman stepping out the same let's
say we're married with kids it's a man
is it exactly the same I'm saying it's
irrelevant because because
it is exactly the same machine no so so
what a mansion and a woman cheating
means the same thing in a relationship
yeah because for me that um The Bondage
the trust is broken I hear that but I'm
saying yes it's the same thing to me
yeah it's the same thing yeah because
okay that it's not the same thing
because a woman a woman wait sorry it's
the same thing to me I understand that
yes I understand it's not the same thing
but it's not to me no I hate in your
opinion but generally speaking is not
the same thing okay because I'm saying
if I can accept for my kids for the
betterment of my children when it means
more for women to step out than it means
for a man to step out then I don't see
how you're saying that you couldn't deal
with the situation because I'm thinking
to myself I'm thinking to myself if
people if we all behave that way then we
wouldn't have a society because if I
want to act based on emotion someone
could slap me and I just kill him yeah
then let's all stop cheating Junior's
all stop cheating if if you did anyway
yeah if you didn't if you don't cheat
you don't put me in this position to
have to walk away so The Simple Solution
don't cheat and be honest if you can do
monogamy be honest about that if you
can't do monogamy be honest about that
and then that way I wouldn't have to I
wouldn't have to I wouldn't have to make
the decision to step away and I can say
marry men women who are less likely to
cheat but you don't want to do that
either so again but you don't know what
I want to do though okay I'm saying
generally what I've seen specifically
generally speaking I could easily say to
women the way you can blase they say oh
just don't cheat that's the solution I
can say well the biggest solution to the
burden of society is by and large is
don't sleep with the same men who who
just fit one certain bracket but we
don't want to do that either when I
speak about stuff yeah I'm speaking
knowing the kind of men like I would go
for I'm speaking knowing what commitment
means to me I'm speaking I mean this is
this is where I'm coming from so I don't
my social media does not dictate to me
what my relationship is going to be like
or my marriage is going to be like what
especially or anything that is not me
doesn't dictate to me what anything is
going to be like do you get me so when
I'm saying that if a man cheats on me
it's not something I'm going to be able
to deal with is because I know how
seriously I take commitments so for me
like breaking that is a massive thing to
me but don't you think your kids future
should be a massive thing to you it will
be when it comes to like okay should I
manage my emotions or put my kid at
every statistical Advantage disadvantage
that I possibly could yeah and maybe you
should put them first you remember again
I said I'm doing the best thing that I
think will work even even as a Christian
woman like they tell you to forgive no
but except when it's infidency
infidelity and um obviously abuse stuff
is when you can actually divorce and
it's in the Bible yeah but my things
again I'm going on what I don't know
where I might be God my husband does
cheat on me I might be in a place where
I'm actually like you know what I'm able
to forgive this and move on so but this
all depends on what I'm going to assess
my situation and assess what's best for
my children if I'm going to be that
because I don't believe in staying with
a man who cheated on me I'm bringing up
every chance he gets I don't believe I
can I'm not going to stay with you and
then every day of my life you do you
make a slight mistake and I'm like well
last time you cheated oh he's like I'm
I don't believe in that I don't believe
in Tormentor if I tell you I forgive you
about something I'm not bringing that up
to make your life miserable so if I
actually found myself in a place where I
cannot I can't I can't let this go it's
not it's not helpful to anything you
know what I would I would say though
that if a man steps out on you and you
have the conversation about potentially
taking them back you should only take
him back on the pretense that he makes a
sacrifice as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible